what's the process of
writing how how do you advise
other humans
if you were to talk to young darwin or
the young young you
and just young anybody and give advice
about how to write and how to write well
about these big topics what would you
say
i said i mean i suppose there's a couple
there's a couple of
points one of them is um
what's the story
what do i want to know what do i want to
convey
why does it matter to anybody
and and very often the most
the biggest most interesting questions
um
the child-like
questions
are the
the one actually that everybody wants to
ask but don't quite do it in case they
look stupid
um and one of the nice things about
being in science is you the more the
longer you're in the more you realize
that everybody doesn't know the answer
to these questions and it's not so
stupid to ask them after all yes um so
so trying to
ask the questions that
that i would have been asking myself for
the age of 15 16 when i when i was
really hungry to know about the world
and didn't know very much about it and
and
um
wanted to be
wanted to go to the edge of what we know
but
um but be helped to get there i i don't
want to be you know
too much terminology and so i i want
someone to keep a clean eye on what the
question is
um
beyond that
i i've wondered a lot i've about who who
am i writing for
and that was in the end
the only answer i had was was myself at
the age of 15 or 16.
um because
even if you you know you can
you just don't know who who's reading
but also where are they reading it
are they reading it in the bath or in
bed or on the on the metro or or
are they listening to an audio book do
do you want to have a
you know a recapitulation
every few pages because you read three
pages at a time or or are you really
irritated by that you know you're going
to get criticism
from people who are irritated by what
you're doing and you don't know who they
are or what you're going to do that's
going to irritate people and in the end
all you can do is just try and
please yourself
um and that means what are these big fun
fascinating and big questions
and what do we know about it
and can i convey that
and i kind of learned in trying to write
um first of all
say what we know
and i was shocked in the first couple of
books how often i came up quickly
against all the stuff we don't know
uh and if you're trying to
i've realized later on in in in
in supervising various physicists and
mathematicians who are phd students and
i you know their math is way beyond what
i can do but the process of trying to
work out what are we actually going to
model here what's going into this
equation is a very similar one to
writing what am i going to put on a page
what's the simplest possible way i can
encapsulate this idea so that i now have
it as a unit that i can kind of see how
it interacts with the other units
and you realize that well if this is
like that and this is like this then
then that can't be true
um
so you end up navigating your own path
through this landscape and that can be
thrilling because you don't know where
it's going
um and i'd like to think that that's one
of the reasons my books have worked for
people because this sense of the
thrilling adventure ride i don't know
where it's going either
so the finding the simplest possible way
to explain the things we know
and the simplest possible way to explain
the things we don't know and the tension
between those two and that's where the
story emerges
what about the edit
do you find yourself
to the point of this
um
you know editing down to mostly harmless
to arrive at simplicity do you find
the edit is productive or does it
destroy the magic that was originally
there no i usually find i i think i'm
perhaps a better editor than i am a
writer i i write and rewrite and rewrite
and rewrite put a bunch of crap on the
page first and then see
the edit word yeah
but then then there's the professional
editors who come along as well and um i
mean that in in in transformer um
the editor came back to me uh after i'd
sent me a few two months after i sent
the first edition he'd read the whole
thing and he said
the first two chapters prevent a
formidable hurdle to the general reader
go and do something about it yes and
it was the last thing i really wanted
your editor sounds very eloquent in
speech yeah well this wasn't this was an
email but uh i i i i thought about it in
you know the bottom line is he was right
and so i put the whole thing aside for
about two months
uh spent the summer this would have been
i guess last summer
uh and then turned to it with full
attention in about september or
something and rewrote those chapters
almost from scratch i kept some of the
material but
it took me a long time to process it to
work out what needs to change where does
it need to i wasn't writing in this time
how am i going to tell this story better
so it's more accessible and interesting
and in the end
i think it was still it's still
difficult it's still biochemistry but
but it has he ended up saying now he's
got a barreling energy to it and i i was
you know because he'd been because he
told me the truth the first time i
decided to believe that he was telling
me the truth the second time as well and
was
was delighted
you